when I can open it is it your studio no
but they don't want to have that many
people it's three people on a couch but
but we definitely wear shirt is this
cool it was opening for me and of
Davidoff and he brought he would come
out with a t-shirt and he would go is
this cool and I go it's very gay don't
come back and I go even Gary and so dove
goes you have to stop doing that cuz
he's compulsive it's sad to me because
I'll kick a dead horse until it's yeah
yeah I made him change to serve 15 times
like he came out finally and he had a
tank that bomb where his hair was coming
out of his and I go perfect he knows but
he's so angry he's just like Chris is
walking around his arms all Langley I
don't give a [ __ ] ah Chris said I would
never fight a guy who you wouldn't I
ain't know cuz we met these guys and
they were Navy SEALs and Chris knew him
from high school and I go those guys are
Navy SEALs you guys yeah I don't get
whatever I go how do you not care that's
so cool yeah okay and he's like I don't
I do they're cool whatever
I go you don't care about ants ever you
guys know I go what would it take to
fight he goes I don't know maybe maybe
if you hit my mom I think my mom would
never fight here yeah loose by the way
special most fourth and the fourth most
watched thing in America on Netflix
amazing hey man you know he is a crazy
combination of fun roll bird and man of
boy but anyway man and and I'm gonna add
one more in there that you're not gonna
like but he has Danes
charm I would watch Dane at the Laugh
Factory even when I wasn't into his
material and I was like this
is the most watchable mother fostered
the most watchable do is Chris right
yeah man a motion to watch about him
here's that it factor but he but so he
has that washability he but he's become
such a great writer like his jokes are
like legitimate like wealth correct when
I told him to now he has a son right I
think Cal helped a lot close talent yeah
close yeah I know they were thinking
Calvin so now the materials can get from
the kids dude wait for I'm telling you
man the kids if you want if you will
talk about them you don't even have to
give your opinions or relate to it
though every single you know my that's
how they're this special father of the
year is an hour special and the whole
premise is every man gets to a point in
their life where they look at their dad
and they think I could beat the [ __ ] out
of this guy and this whole special is
about my son asking me to fight in the
front yard that's good let's see in
today's really fun right yep it's it's a
it's an hour basically it's one basic
long story I've seen it's and so it is
it's look at that nine million views now
I'm in like this special has because
it's relatable and its story so it's
like the best part about having kids is
that we can all tell our individual
stories know be like well so [ __ ]
Brenda know the story right now yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]